- [Instructor] Interpol's
Works of Art division
confirmed that my
great-grandmother's wedding ring
and the ring stolen from the
British Royal Treasury in 1918
are one in the same.
All right, so this is interesting.
They've underlined the word in.
And this expression one in the same
is sometimes something that you might hear
but it's actually the
incorrect expression.
The correct expression
is one and the same.
One
and
the same.
And it's just an expression people use,
to kind of to be extra redundant,
I guess you could say.
'Cause to say that they are one
and to say that they are the same,
well you're saying the
same thing over and over
but it's kinda making it clear,
they are one and the same.
This is an expression.
This is the conventional expression
that you will hear people say.
So this in should be and.
And this one is a pretty hard one
because of how often these
two expressions are confused.
One in the same,
and one one and the same.
People will hear someone
say one and the same
or hear them say it really quickly,
one and the same,
and then it sounds like
they said one in the same
and then that person will
repeat one in the same
and then a lot of other people think
that the expression is one in the same.
But one in the same,
if you think about it,
it just doesn't even make a lot of sense.
It's like having one
thing in the same thing.
So just remember that just
is a little bit strange.
The correct expression
is one and the same.
So we definitely don't wanna
leave it the way it is,
one and the same.
One of the same,
well that's not the expression.
And one over the same,
that's not it for sure as well.